I'm doing well as you can tell by people
can watching this can tell clearly that
we're embarrassed
yes we it's it's worth you coming all
this way exactly um so I just want to
start by saying congrats
apparently when you're playing anyone
named Marie you do exceptional work
there was a reason I think these Marie's
thank you for that there's a reason
these Marie's came into my life at the
same time I don't know what the reason
is
I'm yet to discover the reason but there
was definitely a reason so I had Marie
Colvin and Marie Curie and they both
left a kind of lasting impact on me
you know exceptional women I suppose and
they live inside you they kind of hit me
on a sort of vascular level I think or a
kind of chemical level you know they
they live big lives and it gets into
your bloodstream I think no but they do
I think you know completely and they're
both so amazing and it's so different
yeah and lived at different eras and
yeah and but they're both driven and
with a certain level of ambition that I
really admire and they're unapologetic
and direct and speak their minds and I
think those are all qualities and I
think the thing that really draws me to
characters more than anything these days
is courage and I think they both exhibit
tremendous courage I really do think
that's the quality in people generally
that I admire above all others there is
mm for this film yeah her life is so
incredible and what she was able to
accomplish in the time period even today
yeah you know the fact that it was a
hundred over a hundred years ago when
you were researching what were some of
the things that really shocked you or
were surprised to learn well I think one
of the interesting things that is is
that although it's remarkable to us that
she was a woman in this man's world I
mean you know you see this there's this
amazing photograph of the Solvay
conference in Norway with all the
eminent scientists of the of the era and
they are all met
apart from madam Kelly in the front row
and she's the only one not posing for
the camera so it ends up having the
effect of making all the fellas look
very pompous and she's sort of
just in conversation because it's like
she's too impatient she can't waste just
want to waste her time with anything as
trivial as having her photo taken so it
kind of gave me a big clue as to who she
might have been but she never referred
to herself as a woman or an oddity
because she was a woman it's really her
biographers who have who have sort of
placed her as a woman in a in a man's
world she just lived equality she never
sort of fought for it she just lived it
as her right the other thing is I think
you know this science we now know from
you know laboratories that we see on the
news or in any it's so different from
the the conditions under which pierre
marie curie were working they had a kind
of crumbling garden shed and they were
beating up you know thousands of tons
worth of pitchblende this mineral from
which they extracted uranium ore and
from uranium ore they got to radium and
polonium the two elements that they
discovered but I mean this was not this
was not such a very delicate work in lab
this was hard labor
you know grinding of this this this
matter and then you know boiling it
filtering it distilling it and and and
finally eventually after years of work
ending up with these two extraordinary
elements I mean that must be I just can
never get over you have a marriage
you're you have this neutral adoration
respect and a sort of shared meeting of
minds and together you have two children
but this other child that you bring into
the world is is radium is that that you
unleash upon the world the the magic the
mystery and the might of radioactivity I
kind of it blows my mind because that
night you know there's that night in the
scene in the film when they're still
alone and they've got this glowing
element they've got radium in their
hands and of course we know with our
position in the 21st century that you
know all the all the terrible things as
well as the wonderful things that have
been unreleased and unleashed by the
discovery of radioactivity so it kind of
has an extra resonance for us and
whereas in their time they were just
you know enchanted by the mystery one of
the things is that I think people would
be surprised to learn that back then you
really couldn't make a living being a
scientist you know like you it was they
were it was a struggle just to get the
money and now how people can make you
know it's a completely different era and
Marie Curie after you know she
discovered radium she just she she
explained the mystery of radioactivity
to the world she couldn't afford her own
gram of radium to work on to continue
experimenting on and she was only when
she went to America for the first time
that a woman's society in America
clubbed together and put up the funding
and they all did a kind of crowd project
to buy Marie Curie a gram of radium
which she took back to Paris actually
when when the war broke out I think she
I believe she traveled down to the South
of France when she thought Paris was
going to be bombed she she took a gram
of radium down to the South of France
no no transported it so it was this sort
of incredibly precious thing to her all
her life yeah but yes they never they
never got rich from it for sure they
took us to the museum this morning oh
did they and we saw the case that she
transported the gram of radium and
caches massive and lead led yeah it was
it's a I mean to see what she did you
know the door-handle in the lab is still
ever so slightly radioactive that's very
new that they did not tell us that he's
no clocking back see how much you wrote
you touched it um no they did say that
in 1981 that they had to scrub the lab
to get rid of the hot spots and I
started wondering about all the people
that had gone through you know in the 50
60 s and shows sure and then will her
diaries and books and lab notes they're
all under lock and key because they're
so highly radioactive still um when you
think back on the making of the film
yeah filming in Budapest I believe yeah
uh what's like some of the things you
will always remember and take away from
the experience um I will always remember
the dancer that Marjane Satrapi brought
in because there was a dancer who was
very inspired at the time by the work of
Pierre Marie Curie and she
devised this dance she called the radium
dance and marjan had this vision that
this figure would be a sort of something
in Marie Curie's mind throughout the
whole film she was a dancer called
Loyola and this brilliant dancer very
very tall dancer who's currently working
she's from New York which she's
currently working in a company in
Antwerp she came and did this and she
had so much soul this woman and and the
dance was so beautiful it was electric
it was like wish she had these was given
these big wings so her arms were
extended by sticks and sort of fabric
that seemed like it was glowing and I
found those scenes so incredible and
when Michonne had this idea that when
after Pierre Curie tragically leaves the
story that Madame that Marie Curie would
sort of picture the streets kind of of
Paris almost like a kind of delusional
sort of almost psychedelic horror a
fantasy and and suddenly these dancers
would be everywhere and there was a
moment that we filmed that with I don't
know all these radium dancers down a
street and and and I had to walk
backwards through it and it was so
powerful I mean it was just it was it
was like you know Marie Curie used to
say she made the invisible visible and I
think modern did that with that with
that scene she sort of took somebody's
gut feelings and put them on the screen
what are other scenes I remember I
suppose I mean I really enjoyed things
like having a daughter and I let you
know it's a privilege to sort of play
older than you are and and quite funny
you know I enjoyed sort of before my
time getting to do that scene where the
daughter brings her boyfriend home for
the first time and Marie Curie does not
does the opposite of what you're sort of
hoping your mother would do which is
make your partner feel at ease Marie
Curie puts him on the spot and makes him
feel as uncomfortable as possible and I
found it quite amusing to play that the
actor I played it was very good I'm
always curious obviously when you're
making a movie or do
achieve anything you have your schedule
what are you hoping are you ever looking
at the schedule and like the first day
of filming and hoping for something
because I would imagine the first day
there must be a lot of nerves on set yes
yes I mean that the toughest first day
I've ever had was was on Barney's
version which I did Paul Giamatti and we
had to do this this very very emotional
scene where the as a couple they've
they've they've separated and they come
back together and he and she realizes
that he's got Alzheimer's and his butt
has always loved her it's a very it's a
very beautiful and emotional tea and we
had to do that right at the top of the
show and it was really that's tough
because you have to fill in a lot of
gaps but what did we do we started in
the in the faculties of the Sorbonne
with this film and it was alright but I
got I had to or every day I had to play
young and old so that was the kind of
head screw that you used usually started
the day young and then got started the
day old and then got younger but it was
quite nice I mean it was sort of like
you've progressed back to youth as the
day goes on yeah I would imagine I can't
imagine Arnie's version is also a great
film but I would imagine that has to be
brutal just trying to figure out
everything yeah I mean hopefully you've
done enough thinking and bits of
rehearsal and Marjane Satrapi on this
was very was very good at planting seeds
I think if it was a gardener so over a
sort of year she-she before we started
shooting she'd plant these seeds one of
the seeds that she planted was I came to
meet her in Paris and we were sitting in
one of the cafes you and I were just
talking about before you know and I was
having a croissant of coffee and she
passed me this piece of paper he was in
an envelope and I started to read it and
it was this one of the most beautiful
expressions of love I've ever read and
it was this grief journal that Marie
Curie kept in the days and weeks after
Pierre's death and it was had never
become too light until the year before
we started filming and it was everything
you think you know about Marie Curie
just evaporated in the minute that you
read this pure expression of love from
this woman for this man
and I suddenly I was not expecting it
and I started his tears just sort of
fell into this castle I had and and it
was I I thought from that moment on I
thought okay I know this woman
you know I know the fight you know that
determination that drive and ambition
but the underneath that there was this
well of love that she had and I think
those are the not many people saw it I
don't think you know not many people and
after she lost Pierre I don't think she
ever was able to rediscover that joy
again and it's you know so she was an
extraordinary person but she lived she
lived a difficult life I think